[Applause]
I'm Alisa Strome I'm the associate vice
president research and the executive
director of the pan-canadian
AI strategy at Seaford so one of the key
elements of the pan-canadian AI strategy
is the Canada CFRA I chairs program
which is designed to both recruit and
retain some of the world's great
researchers in AI in Canada as part of
our national ai's strategy we're
investing very deeply in fundamental AI
research and the goal is to really
support the scientists who are
developing and advancing the science of
AI and thinking about what are the
opportunities for its applications and
how do we make those better more
efficient more effective one of the
biggest challenges in AI in Canada and
around the world is around equity
diversity and inclusion right now
internationally around the world only
18% of researchers in AI are women and
clearly that's a problem and I think
it's a problem that we need to solve
it's a problem in Canada just like it is
everywhere else in the world and so it's
see far we're actually really focusing
very distinctly on that issue many of
the training programs that we offer for
graduate students and even high school
students and Beyond across the country
every summer are really focused on
engaging and working with
underrepresented groups in AI a
particular focus on engaging girls and
women and giving them skills and
expertise so that they can
to pursue careers in AI and help us to
drive this technology forward as a
society if we are going to be able to
really truly benefit on what AI can
offer to humanity we need to make sure
that many many different perspectives
are included
[Music]